hey guys i'm alana and welcome to my
channel and today i'm doing another
unboxing because that is the thing that
people on the internet seem to enjoy but
really i am very very excited about this
one it is the majora's mask limited
edition when it's very own skull kid
statue right I don't ya this one wasn't
available in Australia and when I got to
America it had already pre-sold out so
it kind of took some ridiculous look for
me to get it and i mean i can't play the
game because i have an australians
radius and this is a US game so i had to
get a comment from australia so that i
can play the game and the game that i
haven't years basically useless maybe
i'll give it away at the end of this
video that could be a thing that I could
do for your us book but for now let us
open it so before open it let's have a
look at the pretty box you know says
some things about what it is that's
important Zelda Majora's Mask 3d you for
to the 3d s and on the back there's some
French la fin du monde estas 12 sure and
I probably didn't say that right I'm so
sorry French people the world will end
in three days can you stop the
apocalypse in time you bet I can by
traversing time didn't think of that did
you ah Majora's Mask ok the box is open
we have this video game but I can't wait
because it has this yes are the reading
right here so useless really now we pull
out the actual skull kid that I am very
excited about and pretty much my reason
for getting us it looks pretty great so
far
so he's a lot smaller than I expected as
you can see quite sure it fits in a
handspan there was actually another
school kid that was made a very long
time ago that you can see on ebay now
for like hundreds of thousands of
dollars not quite that much but it's
over a thousand sometimes two thousand
ish so I guess this guy is a lot smaller
than that one was but you know I'm gonna
have to skulk in mouth so you may have
seen it if you watch my collectible room
to a video thing that i uploaded not too
long ago that i have a zelda shelf it
has you know two gallons and Link and
aronia and then we have sculpted yeah I
mean only normal this is definitely made
of plastic it's quite nice but really
nice shading on that hat if you guys can
see it's kind of a ever uh shaded
they're beautifully colorful I really
like his pose and I'm just wondering if
I can take the mask off but I don't want
to break it in case I can't and you know
now box is empty I guess you know you
kinda really like to put a lot of detail
into their collectors editions so really
I paid quite a lot of money for this one
thing still though really really happy
to have it so then comes this um I feel
like I should probably give it away to
an American subscriber what are we gonna
do you people never reply on youtube so
it's really really hard to run
competitions on here so what I would do
if you live in the United States and
only if you live in the United States
please tell me what is your favorite
mask in majora's mask and why and then
leave a note on the end saying what is
the best social network to contact you
on candy Instagram direct message I can
do it on Twitter Tumblr Facebook
whatever one you use the most is the one
that I will
pick one women in a week from now and
send you up a copy of Majora's Mask well
I'm at it I also have like I don't know
hundred codes for heroes of the storm so
I'm just gonna hold some of these up for
the closed beta what whoever enters the
middle class gets number one number two
and number three I wanna thank you guys
watching this very short unboxing and
just blame Nintendo for not putting more
stuff in their limited editions that I
really didn't look very close up as all
I wanted was the skull kid so I'm not
sure why I'm now complaining about them
not having much stuff in it and i forgot
to focus my face again but really thank
you guys watching i look forward to
sending one of you a copy of Majora's
Mask us only people are really bad at
getting that part for these videos when
I do it they're like hey this is an
Australian Competition below in the UK
can I enter yep become Australia early
this one is America Renly still no UK
I'm so sorry I'll see you guys next time
some minecraft halo stuff and then we've
got my nice little collection of for
that stuff there and another absolute
favorite shelf here this is my legend of
zelda shelf